imagine you had a favorite food like say
well and showpiece then let's say you
had the opportunity to rock it through a
swarm of your favorite food just opening
your mouth and letting it leap in that's
life for these playful Galapagos
penguins in the waters off the Galapagos
Islands the penguins drive the anchovy
swarm into a shoal of shallow water
bunching the throng even tighter making
the pickins even easier of course every
party needs a pooper in this case the
poopers are pelicans who make like dive
bombers to get in on some of this
feasting
the pelicans water-filled pouches are
too heavy to lift and they're too greedy
to let go and so in a classic case of
taking lemons and making lemonade the
Penguins
pick off anchovies from the beaks of
these pelicans sitting ducks in front of
them only when the pelicans back off on
their gluttony and let go of some of
their cats can they surface and enjoy
the bounty in their beaks leaving the
anchovy banquet down below once more to
these gleeful gluttons